the Urology Specialists of Nevada the
sponsors of this segment are bringing
awareness to prostate cancer all year
round Rocky spoke to a doctor to learn
more
year round is a good time to talk about
prostate cancer and the spread awareness
about it right absolutely as you uh May
notice I don't have a mustache right so
it's not movember it's not officially
prostate cancer awareness month but uh I
think you wish every month should be
Prostate Cancer Awareness Month
absolutely it's so important so let's
get to it you know let's start with the
basic 6. what is the prostate
that's a good question so the prostate
is a gland which is part of the male
reproductive system
it makes most of the fluid that carries
the sperm it's located beneath the
bladder and surrounds the upper part of
the urethra which is the tube that
carries urine from the bladder
as a man ages the prostate tends to
increase in size and a lot of people
this can cause the urethra to narrow
which causes the classic and large
prostate symptoms such as decreased
urine flow this process is called benign
prostatic hyperplasia or BPH
which is not the same as prostate cancer
okay so then what is prostate cancer
so prostate cancer is a disease in which
the cells in the body grow out of
control when cancer starts on the
prostate it's obviously called prostate
cancer not including skin cancer
prostate cancers the most common cancer
in American men you know what are the
symptoms what are we looking out for
different people have different symptoms
for prostate cancer most men do not have
any symptoms if you have any of the
following symptoms be sure to talk to
your doctor right away such as
difficulty starting urination weaker
interrupted flow urinating often
especially at night trouble emptying the
bladder completely pain or burning
during urination blood in the urine or
semen pain in the back hips or pelvis it
doesn't go away
tell us about some of the screenings
that you guys do for the prostate
sure there are two traditional tests
that are commonly used to screen for
prostate cancer there's a blood test
which is called the prostate specific
antigen test it measures the level of
PSA in the blood PSA is a substance made
by the prostate the levels of PSA in the
blood can be higher in many who have
prostate cancer the digital rectal exam
also called the Dre and it's when a
healthcare provider inserts a gloved
lubricated finger into a man's rectum to
fill the prostate for anything abnormal
such as cancer another common test being
done now in addition to or instead of
the Dre is an MRI of the prostate the
MRI can often give us a much clearer
picture of the prostate and help us if
we decide whether or not to proceed with
the biopsy one interesting thing about
prostate cancers not all prostate cancer
needs to be treated research has shown
that lower stage disease
can often be watched with active
surveillance in healthy men with a life
expectancy of 10 plus years especially
if their prostate cancer is higher stage
a radical prostatectomy which is total
removal of the prostate is a good
treatment
men in poor health or who prefer
alternative treatment
May benefit from radiation or other
therapies a thorough discussion with
your doctor by your ah Health life
expectancy and needs will help determine
the right treatment for you
thank you to Urology Specialists of
Nevada for sponsoring this segment they
have four locations across Southern
Nevada for more information call
702-877-0814 or visit usonv.com